um die chipindustrie zu verstehen gehen
wir noch sachsen zu globalfoundries
wir treffen entwicklungschef sven beyer
und unternehmenssprecher jörg drews
bayer zeigt uns die produktion
das sächsische unternehmen ist
eigentlich eine us-firma im staatsbesitz
von abu dhabi viertgrößter hersteller
von computerchips weltweit
globalfoundries den namen liest man so
gut wie nie die firma produziert nur für
andere
des chips an
diversen stellen vom handy sind wir
überall vertreten
alles beginnt mit diesen halb millimeter
dünnen scheiben sogenannten wafer
hergestellt aus geschmolzenen sand die
werden wieder und wieder metall bedampft
umbau belichtet geätzt und so weiter und
so weiter
sie werden von menschen nicht angefasst
und eigentlich sollte dieser raum und
idealerweise menschenleer sein natürlich
muss sich immer wieder mal diese
maschinen gewartet werden aber die wafer
den laufen wirklich vollautomatisch
computer gesteuert zwei bis drei monate
lang von maschine zu maschine
bis zu 3000 arbeitsschritte ist das
schließlich final fertiger chips ist das
macht das ganze so teuer also wenn man
als kunde bei uns ein stück produzieren
will dann muss man ungefähr so 20 bis 50
millionen an
kosten erst mal vor schießen bevor man
überhaupt anfangen kann bei uns zu
produzieren das ist sind also wirklich
enorme kosten in einer halle ungefähr 4
milliarden da eine produktion zwar eine
produktionshalle mit maschinen hier muss
man gefährliche haben wir drei hallen
stehen verglichen mit der chipindustrie
in taiwan ist selbst die hochtechnologie
hier in dresden nur zweiter liga hier
bauen sie so genannte 22 nanometer chips
und größer nur ein winziger bruchteil
der weltproduktion
die kommt hauptsächlich aus südkorea 13
aus china 24 und aus taiwan kommen 47
fast die hälfte aller weltweit verbauten
chips
wir haben vor zehn jahren denke ich mal
den zucht der chipindustrie leider in
europa japan lassen in der ersten liga
sieben nanometer und kleiner hat taiwan
fast ein monopol
diese chips werden eigentlich in nur
zwei ländern gebaut und von nur 24
samsung in südkorea produziert 21
prozent dieser chips taiwan 78 rund vier
fünftel des weltbedarfs bei tsmc
börsenwert 466 milliarden dollar eines
der teuersten unternehmen der welt
ist auch deswegen nancy pelosi die
nummer 3 der amerikanischen politik
anfang august in taiwan amerika ist
taiwans schutzmacht fakt ist pelosi
besucht außer der präsidentin auch tsmc
die welt chip firma
und china reagiert mit raketen und
militär manöver übungen für eine
seeblockade angriffe auf die insel
luftraumkontrolle die größten
chinesischen manöver in dieser region
verletzten gezielt taiwans hoheitsgebiet
denn china wird taiwan notfalls mit
waffengewalt zur wiedervereinigung
zwingen
unsere kampfjets sind um unsere insel
taiwan geflogen um die souveränität und
unser territorium zu sichern marc liu
löscher von tsmc über die drohung aus
china
niemand kann tsmc mit gewalt
kontrollieren militärische gewalt oder
eine invasion wird der smc fabrikation
außer funktion setzen weil es eine sehr
hoch entwickelte produktionsanlage ist
würden die usa taiwan in dieser weise
schützen wenn taiwan nicht einen chip
industrie hätte von der die usa abhängig
sind
ich gehe davon aus dass die usa taiwan
genauso schützen würden wenn es diese
chipindustrie nicht gäbe es hat nur
einfach die die rolle der wirtschaft in
dieser eigentlich politischen
auseinandersetzung noch mal auf eine
ganz andere ebene gehoben was würde denn
einen stopp in der chip produktion in
taiwan bedeutet wenn die chip
unternehmen aus taiwan nicht mehr
liefern können wird innerhalb weniger
monate im grunde die gesamte weltweite
modernen industrie zum erliegen kommen
beispiel bmw das unternehmen das nach
eigener aussage inzwischen bei
globalfoundries produzieren lässt und
durchschnittlich mehrere tausend chips
pro auto einbauen erklärt nach wie vor
rechnen wir damit dass
liefereinschränkungen zu weiteren
produktionsanpassungen in unseren werken
führen können
elektrisch eingeklappten spiegel am
mercedes von sven beyer entwicklungschef
von globalfoundries kann man so ein auto
ohne chips verkaufen nun gibt es ja kein
schloss mehr ohne chips geht der ware
nicht mehr auf man kriegt tatsächlich
sind hybrid wagen
man kriegt den
ohne chips
nicht mehr betankt ja oder geladen in
dem fall
die kofferraumklappe
elektronisch geht ohne chips nicht mal
auf ja wenn man sich das display anguckt
unterhaltungselektronik vorne
vorher schon die klimaanlage per handy
app gestartet so ein display läuft ohne
chips überhaupt nicht navigationssystem
läuft ohne chips nicht können sie mir
irgendeinen bestandteil dieses autos
nennen das ohne chips auskommt das waren
dreieck noch
ja also ich denke dass auch in zukunft
das warndreieck früher später irgendwo
seinen gps standort dann an die polizei
oder den adac oder sonstwas sendet aber
noch geht das warndreieck ohne chips
china die bedeutung der chipindustrie
erkannt präsident jean ping will mit
seiner industrie an die weltspitze das
land hat rund 50 milliarden euro in
einem subventions fonds gesteckt nancy
pelosi präsentiert den us chip 6 52
milliarden dollar subventionen für chip
firmen die in den usa investieren unter
der bedingung keine hochtechnologie nach
china zu liefern und in brüssel
verspricht ursula von der leyen 43
milliarden euro den sogenannten eu chips
act die kommission hat ihn beschlossen
jetzt sollen die mitgliedsländer ihnen
abnicken
wir haben uns das ziel gesetzt 2030 20
prozent der globalen chip-produktion
hier in europa herzustellen heute sind
wir bei 9 prozent wir wollen bis 2030
bei 20 prozent sein weil wir aber wissen
dass sich der bedarf des weltmarkt in
dieser zeit verdoppeln wird bedeutet das
eine vervierfachung unseres aufwand
weltweit der versuch wenigstens ein
bisschen unabhängig zu werden von der
chipschmiede von chinas küste das
beispiel taiwan zeigt uns oder
verdeutlich und sehr stark dass wir uns
in eine neue ära der globalisierung
begeben die geprägt ist von
geopolitischen risiken und zeigt uns
auch wie anfällig die extrem global
vernetzten lieferketten sind und mit
welchen wirtschaftlichen kosten wie zu
rechnen haben sollte es dort zu einem
konflikt kommen aber ich halte es für
nicht ausgeschlossen dass es zu weiteren
eskalation kommt denn die zielsetzung
chinas bezüglich taiwans sollten uns
allen klar sein die sind die einnahmen
mit taiwans und die integration in die
volksrepublik mit gewalt zur not